I've been intrigued by this question
of whether we could evolve
or develop a sixth sense --
a sense that would give us seamless access
and easy access to meta-information
or information that may exist somewhere
that may be relevant to help us
make the right decision
about whatever it is
that we're coming across.
And some of you may argue,
"Well, don't today's cell phones
do that already?"
But I would say no.
When you meet someone here at TED --
and this is the top networking place,
of course, of the year --
you don't shake somebody's hand
and then say,
"Can you hold on for a moment
while I take out my phone and Google you?"
Or when you go to the supermarket
and you're standing there
in that huge aisle
of different types of toilet papers,
you don't take out your cell phone,
and open a browser,
and go to a website to try to decide
which of these different toilet papers
is the most ecologically
responsible purchase to make.
So we don't really have easy access
to all this relevant information
that can just help us
make optimal decisions
about what to do next
and what actions to take.
And so my research group at the Media Lab
has been developing a series of inventions
to give us access to this information
in a sort of easy way,
without requiring that the user
changes any of their behavior.
And I'm here to unveil our latest effort,
and most successful effort so far,
which is still very much
a work in process.
I'm actually wearing the device right now
and we've sort of cobbled it together
with components that are off the shelf --
and that, by the way, only cost
350 dollars at this point in time.
I'm wearing a camera,
just a simple web cam,
a portable, battery-powered
projection system with a little mirror.
These components communicate
to my cell phone in my pocket
which acts as the communication
and computation device.
And in the video here we see
my student Pranav Mistry,
who's really the genius
who's been implementing
and designing this whole system.
And we see how this system
lets him walk up to any surface
and start using his hands
to interact with the information
that is projected in front of him.
The system tracks
the four significant fingers.
In this case, he's wearing
simple marker caps
that you may recognize.
But if you want a more stylish version,
you could also paint your nails
in different colors.
And the camera basically
tracks these four fingers
and recognizes any gestures
that he's making
so he can just go to,
for example, a map of Long Beach,
zoom in and out, etc.
The system also recognizes iconic gestures
such as the "take a picture" gesture,
and then takes a picture
of whatever is in front of you.
And when he then walks
back to the Media Lab,
he can just go up to any wall
and project all the pictures
that he's taken,
sort through them and organize them,
and re-size them, etc.,
again using all natural gestures.
So, some of you most likely
were here two years ago
and saw the demo by Jeff Han,
or some of you may think,
"Well, doesn't this look like
the Microsoft Surface Table?"
And yes, you also interact
using natural gestures,
both hands, etc.
But the difference here
is that you can use any surface,
you can walk up to any surface,
including your hand,
if nothing else is available,
and interact with this projected data.
The device is completely
portable, and can be --
(Applause)
(Applause ends)
So, one important difference
is that it's totally mobile.
Another even more important
difference is that in mass production,
this would not cost more tomorrow
than today's cell phones
and would actually not
sort of be a bigger packaging --
could look a lot more stylish
than this version
that I'm wearing around my neck.
But other than letting some of you
live out your fantasy
of looking as cool as Tom Cruise
in "Minority Report,"
the reason why we're really
excited about this device
is that it really can act
as one of these sixth-sense devices
that gives you relevant information
about whatever is in front of you.
So we see Pranav here
going into the supermarket
and he's shopping for some paper towels.
And, as he picks up a product,
the system can recognize
the product that he's picking up,
using either image recognition
or marker technology,
and give him the green light
or an orange light.
He can ask for additional information.
So this particular choice here
is a particularly good choice,
given his personal criteria.
Some of you may want the toilet paper
with the most bleach in it
rather than the most ecologically
responsible choice.
(Laughter)
If he picks up a book in the bookstore,
he can get an Amazon rating --
it gets projected
right on the cover of the book.
This is Juan's book, our previous speaker,
which gets a great rating,
by the way, at Amazon.
And so, Pranav turns the page of the book
and can then see additional
information about the book --
reader comments, maybe sort of information
by his favorite critic, etc.
If he turns to a particular page,
he finds an annotation by maybe
an expert or a friend of ours
that gives him a little bit
of additional information
about whatever is on that particular page.
Reading the newspaper --
it never has to be outdated.
(Laughter)
You can get video annotations
of the events that you're reading about.
You can get the latest sports scores, etc.
This is a more controversial one.
(Laughter)
As you interact with someone at TED,
maybe you can see
a word cloud of the tags,
the words that are associated
with that person
in their blog and personal web pages.
In this case, the student
is interested in cameras, etc.
On your way to the airport,
if you pick up your boarding pass, it can
tell you that your flight is delayed,
that the gate has changed, etc.
And, if you need to know
what the current time is,
it's as simple as drawing a watch --
(Laughter)
(Applause)
on your arm.
So that's where we're at so far
in developing this sixth sense
that would give us seamless access
to all this relevant information
about the things that we may come across.
My student Pranav, who's really,
like I said, the genius behind this.
(Applause and cheering)
(Applause ends)
He does deserve a lot of applause,
because I don't think he's slept much
in the last three months, actually.
And his girlfriend is probably
not very happy about him either.
But it's not perfect yet,
it's very much a work in progress.
And who knows, maybe in another 10 years
we'll be here with the ultimate
sixth sense brain implant.
Thank you.
(Applause)